Alright guys, so in this lecture we are going to talk about entry patterns. So there are two entry patterns that I use for my entries regardless of what strategy that I'm using. So I could be using ABC and I'd be using those entry patterns. I could be using the under over patterns strategy I could be using ABCD. Well, for ABCD, you don't really need to see the market structure shift.
look for Microsoft shift on ABCD as well. It can work out greatly as well. So what are entry
patterns? So let's assume that you have a POI right here. So this is your POI. And there is one
called the inducement. So let me just put this, the inducement entry pattern. And then there is
BOS liquidity pattern, right?
So these two patterns are pretty well.
So let's assume that you have a py.
So this box right here is a py.
So this is inducement.
So let me just put this.
So price is coming back into your py.
And it just reverses before you end up tapping into your py.
Now what does it say?
It's like calling in early buyers.
So this is like manipulation.
So when people are going to see that the price is going up from this level, they are going
to form more in.
They're going to buy here, here, here and here, right?
Because they think that this price has found the bottom.
In reality, this is liquidity being generated by the market makers.
So when price, so the people will have their stock losses below this level and there will
be breakout artist, right, as well. We're going to take trades when this level breaks.
Surprise comes back into the POI, actual POI, and then it goes back up. So this is an
inducement entry pattern that you can use with every single stretch. Okay, whether it's ABC,
whether it's any other, okay, whether it's auto flow, it works perfectly well. So you see you have
have inducement, right? This is our POI.
Price comes back into a POI and you would have taken your entry here and boom.
It goes up. Now we have the BOS liquidity pattern and what is it? So you have your POI,
right? So price comes into your POI, right? And then you have a change of collector or
for market structure shift.
And when you have change of predictor, right,
you would have your autoblock here at the extreme zone, right?
So you wanna take your entry from the extreme autoblock.
So you have marked out your extreme field of autoblock plus variable gap.
If price without tapping in goes up and breaks another structure like this.
So this is break of structure or market structure break, right?
This is market structure break.
And we have this
Fairly gap with auto block and price never came back here and before it came back
here it made another higher high.
Now a lot of people will take their entry from this level considering that this is a break
of structure, right?
So a lot of people that will take their entry from here.
However, they fail to notice that this right here is liquidity.
Surprise is going to come back down into the lower time.
Oh, into the py, right?
Not the lower time frame, but the py and it's going to go boom, like this.
So remember this pattern.
Now, price can actually do something like this as well.
So let me just go out this out, delete this out,
and delete this out as well.
So price can actually come back.
And before price shifts the market structure,
or before market structure shift happens,
price can actually create a break of structure
and a liquidity pattern.
So this is perfectly fine as well.
So yes, you have a change of liquidity here,
or market structure shift here.
price also had a break of structure. So your entry would be valid from this level as well.
It's not necessary for price to shift the market structure and then break the structure.
No. Even if price hasn't shifted the market, it can create a break of structured pattern,
which is going to look something like this. So you have a break of structure and you also
of ginger pressure here and that is absolutely fine as well because this is
liquidity level so make sure you know that and when price comes back into your
POI, it's gonna go up like that. So these are two entry patterns and I have
explained these entry patterns in one of my YouTube videos so please refer
in detail okay I have you know explain this in detail by showing examples on YouTube so I don't
think it's necessary for me to you know just repeat the same thing in the course as well you can
go to my YouTube channel I'll actually link it in this video description so you can watch it on
the YouTube so these are simple entry patterns that you can use in every strategy right so
So, yeah guys, I'll see you in the next lecture.